all right so what you're seeing here are
solutions found to this bipedal Walker
problem by a new algorithm called poet
so as you might guess the challenge is
to keep this little thing here walking
to the right as far as you can while it
encounters various obstacles and it is
and remains a challenging reinforcement
learning problem to to have an agent
learn to overcome various obstacles and
and walk well in different environments
so the the the paper we're going to look
at is called poet it's called it's by
uber engineering and the full
pronunciation is the paired open-ended
Trail Blazer and lossy generating
increasingly complex and diverse
learning environments and their
solutions by Roy Wong Joe layman Jeff
clued in Kenneth Oh Stanley as I said
from uber AI F labs so as you already
saw the challenge and they take on is
this bipedal Walker problem now their
method is very general and not limited
to this problem but this is the problem
that they focus on and a jump some of
the explanations here and dig right into
the problem as you can see the problem
is the following you have this thing
here which is the Walker and it has two
legs and specifically it has four joints
so the four joints are here - and here -
and you can give a torque on all of the
four joints so it's a it's basically a
for output problem and you do have
sensors as input so the inputs I believe
is a lidar so the lighter is this red
line you see here I think it has 16 of
those in various angles and also it has
pressure detection on the feet I believe
to see whether or not they are in
contact with the ground and if
I'd also have a kind of an an angle so a
a gyroscope in that tells you which
angle with respect to the ground the
head is so you have various sensors on
these things and you're able to
basically control what the legs are
doing and your goal is to make this go
as far to the right and as fast as
possible you see the reward down here is
negative 100 if the robot falls over
that means if the head hits the ground
and then it is 130 times Delta X that's
how far you go to the right - the whole
angle and the whole angle as I said is
this angle here so you want to keep it
as stable as possible because if there
if there's a difference in the angle
first step then you get penalized and
also you get penalized for each torque
you apply so you want to kind of apply
minimal force on the joints in order to
go very far but I'm by far the most
important point is to go to the right as
far and as fast as you can there is an
end here somewhere and if you reach it
you get a score that is above 230 and
they choose the limit of 230 here to
determine so if the agent gets to 30 or
more than it has solved the environment
that's what they they claim that's from
experience so as you see the environment
has various obstacles here there are
holes that you can fall into that you
need to jump or step over there are
these kind of stumps here they can be of
various height so this is a bit shorter
and this is a bit longer and the general
terrain has a roughness in this game
this can go to two very rough
from very smooth so this is a
parameterised environment and there of
obviously they are able to generate
these environments from parameters and
the the goal now is to have an agent
that works well in any environment that
you can think of right so here on the
left you see this is very challenging
down the stairs this also isn't too easy
because there's a gap here and there are
five parameters of these of these
environments so there is the general
roughness of the terrain that means kind
of how many hills it hasn't how fast
they're coming
there is the stump lower bound stump
upper bound I believe so how high the
stumps are and also how long the gaps
are and with these parameters you
control how difficult and environment is
so the straightforward thing to do is
simply to let's say sample environments
and have a reinforcement learning
approach to this and that usually
doesn't work um I already you want to
see this without having talked about
what the algorithm is this is the
approach where you try this thing is
called evolution strategies but you can
think of it as just an straightforward
optimization procedure so there's an
agent and there's an environment and
you're trying to solve the environment
using just straightforward optimization
now the evolution strategies are not
your classic orell algorithm but you can
compare it to to it it's just that these
people they like the more I have a
feeling they like the more esoteric
ahahah learning algorithms in any case
so you see in these um in these
environments large gap or rough surface
and so on
these are supposed to be deployed in
figures three so these two environments
and also these environments here the
evolution strategy so the classic
approach if you just straightforward
optimize they get very low scores on
average whereas poet gets here very high
scores above the 230 threshold so what's
happening if you're trying to just solve
these environments from scratch you
basically don't really have a big chance
of solving them because let's say you're
here and you're trying to move to the
right
you know you might learn how to do this
and the you see this from scratch
solution actually manages to get to the
right but then as soon as you reach this
you're in this gap and you just fall
down the gap because all you've learned
so far is how to move right right so
what you would need to do is you would
need to plan ahead
like what poet does you need to see that
there is a gap you need to plan ahead
and already lift up a leg in order to
then step over the gap here and then do
a little jump right here and this
sequence of action this kind of planning
ahead it is very difficult to learn this
for a classic oral algorithm because you
basically get reward for everything you
do so initially you get reward for
moving to the right so that's ten if you
reach here another ten if you reach here
and so there is another ten if you reach
here and another ten if you reach here
whereas if you lift up your leg that's
like minus five because now this you've
changed this angle and we saw this is
negative reward right so a classic
optimization algorithm will always fall
into the hole because that is where you
get the immediate reward whereas you'd
have to you'd have to do a sequence of
action that doesn't give you a reward
right now but it gives you more reward
later and in order to learn this you
need a kind of a
a better better algorithm that just
straightforward optimization so maybe I
can explain this if you have a maze here
is the start and here is the goal and
there is like walls the walls or
something like this what you need to do
is go around here but what a classic
optimization algorithm does is always
like it goes here because that's ever so
closer to the goal and then it just gets
stuck because it can't fathom that it
needs to go around here so it needs to
go farther away before it gets closer so
these people we've talked about this
before and like open-ended learning
novelty search what you would want to do
is you would want to gradually build up
solutions that can explore the space
like go here go here go here and
basically build up these solutions and
there are two components to what this
poet algorithm does so the first
component is curriculum learning
curriculum learning what is curriculum
learning mean curriculum learning means
that you start off with easy tasks and
you increasingly build up more and more
and more complex tasks so let's say I
have an environment here and I'm going
to attempt to draw and at the beginning
we just kind of start off with this flat
surface right and here is our little
Walker right here and we will just train
it to move right on that and that should
be doable with kind of a with a classic
approach and then we gradually move to
more difficult environments so maybe
we'll make it a bit more rough right and
an agent that can already walk to the
right already kind of has think of it as
a pre-training
in like NLP you can then get more and
more challenging and then maybe at some
you can build in you can build in the
gap right so you build any one of these
gaps and I would already knows how to
move to the right and now I might
actually it might might learn to jump a
small gap right if you make it small at
the beginning not like this one down
here there's a very large gap but if you
make it small by accident it might
stumble over it and then learn and
continuously how to master the gap so
this is the curriculum learning approach
it means that from environment to
environment you get harder harder and
harder challenges so first flat then
more rough then more rough with a gap
and so on the second approach the second
ingredient to poet is what I what they
call stepping-stone learning or transfer
learning or things like this and that's
where you kind of have to think of this
not as a single agent optimizing but as
a population of agents so let's say you
do this curriculum learning right and
you're getting fairly well here at some
rough terrains right more more and more
rough terrains but you in parallel you
also have a second optimization
procedure
you also start out kind of flat but with
this thing you go as we said before
small gap you keep it flat but you just
increase the number of gaps here right
gap right whereas over here you just
keep making the terrain rougher and
rougher right so what is what the the
philosophy is that an agent that might
you know be able to master this rougher
terrain it might actually that skill
because here you this kind of this kind
of looks like a gap here the skill of
hopping over this gap
here might actually transfer to the
environment over here where you do have
a proper you know a gap in the
environment or the skill that you learn
from an environment where you have one
of these stumps right so here let's draw
in one of these stumps where you have to
go over and if you have an a walker that
can successfully walk over this that
skill now might transfer over here in
order to get over this over this picky
terrain here so the idea of poet is to
start off with a generic flat very easy
environment and then spawn new ones so
you want to spawn new environments in
kind of a hereditary way so this one
might get a bit rougher this one might
include this and this one might include
a gap or something like this and then
again you want to spawn new environments
and more rough more more rough with a
stump here and this one retains the gap
sorry and this one we now gets two gaps
and so on and you want to continuously
train these and then always you want to
check whether or not the skill that you
learn over here might actually transfer
to anyone over here so you get this tree
of this continuous tree of solutions and
once you improve on one branch this
might actually be good on another branch
right they always make the comparison to
let's say biological evolution where a
strategy that works over here for birds
is all of a sudden can be cross adopted
by mammals
it for an entirely different problem but
the same skill might be valuable yeah so
this this is basically the two
ingredients of poet and now I want to
show you the complete poet algorithm so
what does it do you start off with an
initial environment right and in poet
every environment is paired with an
agent so there is one agent per
environment right so for the time steps
what you do is first of all you go
through your environments and you mutate
them and we already seen these
environments they can be generated from
a parameter vectors so we have five
numbers right how rough house stompy and
how how wide the gaps are let's say we
have three numbers - - and this might be
one this might be two this might be five
right so what you want to do is you want
to mutate them right you want spawn
children and each of these parameters
has a chance of mutating this might be
one three five and this environment
might be one four six and this one might
be two to five right you spawn new ones
you already see that the requirement
here is that you can actually have
environments that are procedurally
generated and mutated like this where a
small mutation probably is gonna lead to
a small change in the environment in any
case you mutate them and then you you
wanna lets you want to optimize your a
each agent so each of these environments
is paired with a new agent
that always tries to solve that
particular environment so now within one
environment you simply do your classic
optimization we already saw here the
evolution strategy is akin to a classic
optimization algorithm from
reinforcement learning
all right so each agent you optimize for
a couple of steps right not fully every
time but for a couple of steps so each
agent including the one in the original
environment each agent is continuously
trained on its environment throughout
the process of course like you have to
be you have found the computation so you
need to drop out the very old ones but
in principle continuously as all of this
goes on all the agents are always
trained on their environments so the
agent here this walker will always try
to solve this particular environment and
the walker here that is now newly
generated when the environment is
generated will only try to solve this
particular environment throughout the
whole algorithm right and then all right
so you do mutations you spawn new ones
and then you do a couple of steps in
optimization right an es step and then
you do this transfer attempt right what
you want to do is you want to evaluate
all the candidates on all the
environments in principle like you can
you can cut this down but in principle
you want to go through the environments
and say ok this environment right here
when I evaluate all of the other agents
in this environment you can do this in a
couple of different ways where you just
straight-up try them or try to optimize
them for a few steps to see whether they
can be adapted easily to that
environment but ultimately you have to
come up with a criterium to say for each
agent is the agent better or worse than
the agent that is
continuously trained on this environment
if it's worse then you keep this one if
if anyone is better then you transfer
that better one to replace this one
right and you please click copy it over
to this new environment and that's where
this transfer learning comes in so you
continuously trying all the agents on
all the environments and if they are
better you transfer them right so here
you say if the environment score is
better than the one that you have
transferred all right now there's a lot
hidden here for example in this mutate
environment step they do check whether
or not the new mutated environments are
not too hard and not too easy and that
basically means whether or not the
agents can solve them but not solve them
too easily
they also check whether the environments
are enough novel so you make a couple of
checks here you solvable and that that
means not too easy and not too hard
right
so they need to pass like a certain
score but they need to be kind of
solvable to a to an okay score so
there's a score range and also novel
they check whether or not the of the
mutated environments are novel enough
and I believe they just do this by
calculating the the distance between two
environments in terms of their parameter
vectors so I'm to determine whether or
not these are novel and sorry I don't
mean the distance just between two but
the distance of all of the ones you've
seen so far so if we go to original very
beautiful drawing here
where is material if you create a new
environment let's say you create a new
environment right here then you
wanna check it against all environments
you've seen so far to determine whether
or not it is new or not so you want to
create the distance to all of these and
if you have enough distance to your
nearest neighbors then you are novel and
that's kind of how they they determine
whether environment is new all right so
that's basically the poet algorithm you
continuously create new environments by
mutation you ensure that they are
solvable not hard enough
sorry not too hard but hard enough
ensure that they are novel and then you
optimize each agent for its own
environment continuously as the process
goes on and so it's not I want to stress
this it's not only the frontier so
you're not only looking at the newest
generation but you're always looking at
all of the generation of the because the
older ones while the environments are
easier they have been optimized for
longer on these environments so the
skills might be very handy so you always
want to look at your entire population
and then you do crucially do this these
transfer attempts so that's the poet
algorithm there is a lot hidden here and
I don't want to stress that just if you
just look at the amount of hyper
parameters there's so many hyper
parameters in this how much you transfer
how much you mutate how many steps you
do and each of these subroutines here
has a billion hyper parameters and
learning rates and and so on so to me
that's uh that is kind of if I look at
this algorithm I am very scared if I
attempted to do something like this
myself it is going to be a long and hard
thing to evaluate all of these different
hyper parameters that you have to do
shortly want to dip into what the
evolution strategy
does just so you know because you just
might be familiar with your classic the
classic reinforced algorithm so in
policy gradient methods what you do is
you scale your parameters of your neural
network which is you can if this is your
policy then there your policy network
here you want to scale the gradient
according to your reward
so in classic reinforcement learning
this here would be the reward you got
which basically means if you did an
action and you got high reward you want
to make your network do that action more
right here in evolution strategies what
you do is and you spawn it's a different
way of doing the same thing basically
you spawn different environments and
sorry you spawn you spawn different
agents so you have your current
parameters and you want to spawn a
number of no easy versions of those
parameters and then you want to evaluate
each one right and now you want to
adjust your parameters into the
direction of that particular so
basically you're here with your
parameters you create a bunch of noisy
versions of it right and let's say these
two perform really well you want to
adjust your parameters into the
direction of those two right that's
basically what this says so this is the
noisy version and then this is the noise
that produced the noisy version so if if
if this is high if this number here is I
then you will adjust your parameters
into that direction it's a fairly cool
way if you especially if you can't back
prop
your policy as is pretty neat things so
this is the es step algorithm but you
can think of it just as a RL algorithm
all right so they do various experiments
to show that this actually has merits I
already shown you if you're trying if
you take the same environments and try
to solve them directly by this evolution
step then it will not succeed because of
the problems we've discussed before now
the comparison is a bit unfair because
um of course these environments for poet
poet the problem here is you can't have
it solve a particular environments
because the environments they constantly
change right you constantly mutate the
environments you never know where it's
going it's not directed so if your goal
is to solve a particular environment you
cannot do it with poet you can hope that
the agent that comes out will perform
well I didn't do something like this but
I believe I believe that these
environments that they test on here are
ones that appeared during the poet rung
right so it's kind of an unfair
comparison I feel - to do this on an
environment that you know dissing virus
poet agent actually comes from an
environment that poet has generated in
it's all mutation tree curriculum while
building it up and then the poor es
algorithm is simply tasked with solving
that particular environment from scratch
so es always keep in mind this is this
can have a goal this doesn't have a goal
right that's kind of the drawback but as
you can see poet does get super high
scores
whereas es the classic algorithm
completely fails and they also
investigate the importance of transfer
learning so they compared to like a
classic
classic curriculum learning algorithms
there are curriculum learning algorithms
where you can continuously try to build
up the difficulties of these
environments but you also do it in a
goal-directed way so as I said if you
have an environment that has like a gap
and then a stump
a high stump or two high stumps you
wanna start out flat and then maybe
building a small gap and a small stump
and so on until you are here it's very
much goal directed but it doesn't have
this kind of population with transfer
learning aspect of poet so if they
compare this you can see here the red
the red the red one sorry I colored it
blue stupidly the red one is whatever
poet was able to solve now these two
five dimensions of the parameters and
the more on the outside it is the harder
the environment and for the same for the
same environment the blue one is what
the curriculum learning algorithm has
managed so it's the best environment the
curriculum learning algorithm has been
able to solve while trying to build up
to thee so if we take this here is the
environment that oh it solved again the
comparison is kinda unfair because we're
starting out from an environment that
poet has already solved and then we're
trying to build our way up to it with
the classic algorithm by basically again
this is it's comparing a non
goal-directed thing something that just
happened to a goal-directed process that
needs to get this particular environment
to work in any case at some point this
curriculum learning algorithm will fail
like let's say that's here that's the
environment that has somewhat of a gap
but no stump right and that would be the
the blue line here they do like five
runs
and they plot them here and you can see
every time the classic curriculum
learning algorithm manages to only solve
a much much less challenging environment
than the poet algorithm achieved even
though it's it's trying to reach exactly
that right and so here they show the
difference so if you just take
classified environments if it's just
challenging than the classic algorithm
the curriculum learning algorithm can
solve it somewhat so the distance is
close to zero but as you go more and
more challenging the distance between
poet and the classic it becomes larger
and larger they do give some examples of
what this transfer learning does so they
have this parent environment that just
kind of slouches forward on the ground
and then the child environment has a
mutation that has now little stumps in
it right so you can't get over it right
now but the child environment because
it's it's a small stump so it might
stumble across learns to lift its leg
here and it transfers this back to the
parent right at a later iteration which
is pretty cool and then the parent um
gets even better as a result of that
transfer so we have to transfer learning
events here that mutually help these
agents remember both the parent and the
child are continuously trained as the
process goes on all right and they do
some more things where they do actual
poet not a classical poet without
transfer learning and they see that okay
the poet without transfer is able to
solve some of the very challenging
problems but never reaches the extremely
challenging stage and that's kind of
their argument why the transfer learning
is necessary so in total I would say
this is a Google algorithm it has many
many many many many many hyper
parameters
and these experimental results with that
many hyper parameters you need to take
it with a grain of salt because it's
always possible that they just haven't
put as much effort into the comparisons
as they have into their own thing to get
it to work all right with that I wish
you a nice day and check out the paper
they have lots of descriptions check out
the blog post where they have animations
and the YouTube video and without
bye-bye